good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy tuesday to
everyone
i hope you have a beautiful day
that's gorgeous claudia is that an
original a tuesday original
a song is only as beautiful as the
person who sings it
so i think the song is only as beautiful
as the person who you're singing it too
that's an interesting perspective not
necessarily one i agree with but i love
hearing you know differing perspectives
this is like the view
which would make that particular song so
[ __ ] ugly
welcome back to the morning toast
jackie's in a feral mood i've just
learned about your favorite word new
favorite word alert i just found out
i've been mispronouncing that word i was
saying feral
fiero feral
feral oh speaking of you know the
internet is ablaze with your
pronunciation um we posted a clip from
our show yesterday of the color
t-a-u-p-e can you say it again how you
pronounced it top
taupe
i like top if it was meant to be if it
was meant to be tope it would be t-o-p-e
no and the thing is i knew what you were
i knew what you were saying
every one day because everyone has a top
pair of underwear hunter
i'm so unwell today and i'm sure you are
too because you've had a morning but
like i am harried
frazzled
and feral
feral actually oh you're one of those
just letting you know the internet is
like obsessed with the word feral i
didn't make it like it's a tick-tock
thing it's an internet original not a
claudia original yeah which means it's
obviously like less cool but obviously
obviously what are they saying it about
like when you just act insane you're
like a feral animal
oh yeah i know you are no i am i've had
the busiest morning work work work brand
meeting brand this brand that ah it's
exams are just obsessed with you they're
clamoring for you to be their
spokesperson and i don't blame them no
and the thing is is like when you're a
mogul like these are things you have to
make time for
and it's just tough because you know
what do you prioritize
what do you prioritize that's a great
i'm asking you like what's your priority
myself
okay
second
theo
okay third this doesn't sound like a
mogul yet no no you're talking about
like work wise actually like what takes
priority in my in my list of yeah sure
answer however you want i would say my
number one priority when it comes to
work is the toast like quality
audio quality video quality
humor quality yeah performance
performance agency social media the
social overall branding community
management like the morning toast is my
number one priority that's good you have
your priorities in order yeah number two
priority is probably my tour
number three priority is probably you
know managing the girl with no job brand
you know working with other brands
creating content for you know my various
social media platforms
oh now you are multi-platform you're a
multi-hyphenate creator yeah because the
big news of the day and what you've been
prioritizing and your hard work has paid
off
is that we hit a hundred thousand
subscribers on youtube thanks to the
rebeccas the gertrudes the emily's the
sarah's and the rachel's
and everyone who subscribed and got us
to 90k and then those five took us over
the line i really think it was probably
the gertrudes if i just like i'm not a
betting person but if i were to bet it
was all the gertrudes um yeah that's
really what i wanted to come on here and
talk about today i'm so overwhelmed and
honestly it's not one of those things
where it happens and then you're like
let down by the excitement of it all
it's very exciting i can let you guys
know and honestly what i wanted to come
on here and say was just express
gratitude for the toasters like being as
excited about this milestone as we are
like it's on their page like there's no
reason like they should give a [ __ ] like
about this podcast they listen to but
everyone was like doing the most getting
their husbands their co-workers like
create gmail accounts logging into
accounts they haven't uh you know been
active on in 15 years really getting
excited and then once we hit it like
their excitement matched mine and that
was really like i can't imagine like
caring about anyone else you know so for
me it's like huge that other people
cared about a milestone of ours and i'm
really i'm humbled i really am and i'm
extremely grateful that's so beautiful
claudia so is that your official
acceptance speech or is there anyone
else that you want to thank well of
course i want to thank god because he
made me so funny and gave me the best
sister in the planet who's also
so funny so like
none of those things would happen if it
weren't for you know
um so to him
i'm extremely grateful and i'm not one
of these people who thinks god is a
woman i'm just not
to him or her no
the bible uh is hospital h.i.m
the bible is extremely clear you know
all of his pronouns all of his verbs are
masculine so um i'm all for you know
empowering women except when it comes to
the hallmark channel and whether god is
a woman
i wonder if there's a version of the
bible i'm sure there is
with god's pronouns as female
i'm sure there is i'm sure a lot of
people find like spiritual healing and
guidance from it and i absolutely love
that journey for you but the thing about
religion is that it's more personal than
comedy
so my personal you know religious
experience is that of a masculine god
and that's i'm not saying that's
everyone but i'm just saying i'm not one
thing you should know about me you know
to our hundred thousand subscribers and
millions of fans across the planet
is um i don't pray to a male god i do
okay and he answered your prayers
he answered my prayers so thank you to
everyone for bringing bringing us to
this milestone we obviously couldn't
have done it without you because making
a hundred thousand gmails is not
something i'm below but it's not
necessarily something i want to take on
you know no it's not there on your list
of priorities so it's important to note
like i thought literally once we hit
100k like
larry the guy who started google like
would call me up and be like your plaque
is enroute mrs ashrae thank you so much
for the premium content um but it
actually doesn't happen that way we have
to wait about a week for youtube to
reach out to us and then once they do
reach out to us we have to go under
review
so
your account is only eligible if you
post original content which we do we
don't resurface you know like music
videos or anything like that um and we
have no copyright claims against us
which to my understanding we don't since
we create original content so i don't
want to jinx it i think we should be in
the clear in terms of eligibility but
it's also important to note that youtube
can you know give out plaques at their
own discretion so if there's a
disgruntled former toaster who works at
youtube and has power like she could
literally be like and don't get me don't
get it twisted that disgruntled former
toaster is a she unlike god
um
she can say like you know they can they
can deny you for no reason yeah it's
really up to their whims and
wishes
so we're in their hands i have faith
that like we follow the rules we're good
content creators like i don't think it
should be
really a controversial decision but
we'll see you know we we could always be
surprised well another thing that takes
you out of the running for eligibility
is whether you're spreading
misinformation and i did just say that
god is a man
so someone could interpret that as
misinformation right and you're also
claiming that there is a god someone
else i also make that think that's
misinformation i also did claim that
paul rudd taught me gymnastics which is
true by the way i think um but some
people could obviously paul rudd
included they consider the
yeah so it's just a it's a waiting game
at this point we'll of course keep you
updated on the process as we have been
this entire time and i just think it's
also important to remember that just
because we've hit 100 000 subscribers
doesn't mean that you should
not subscribe you know not to continue
to subscribe and just like make your
presence known and now it's like i feel
sometimes like at the end of the year i
feel akin to the spotify listeners
because we get spotify wrapped and i'm
like who's listening the most hours on
spotify
and other times like i feel akin to the
apple users because i'm looking at the
charts i'm like where why aren't you
guys listening on apple i want to be
number one on the charts
but these days we're feeling really akin
to the youtube subscribers not only the
100k which means the world to us means
everything it's everything we could ever
wish for ever but it's like we did all
of this
new girls like i'm sweating in every
orifice for the youtube not for the
podcast for the youtube and so i'm just
feeling really close to them
no also i literally was talking about
about this yesterday it's important for
people to know people are always
wondering about you know like the back
end of our business
running a podcast like an audio podcast
is actually an extremely low cost
business um which is why anyone can
start a podcast it's really an
accessible medium
becoming content creators on youtube in
a high quality sense is extremely
expensive and we spend like copious
amounts of money per month renting space
you know all the things that all the
resources that are involved in getting
this up when literally our youtube
audience is about five or ten percent of
that people who actually listen to the
morning toast as a podcast but that's on
being vain and needing to see ourselves
on camera and that's on
putting out the sort of content that we
want to see in the world and like i know
if i was not the host of the show i
would be a toaster 100 on youtube and i
would watch on youtube yeah yeah of
course yeah of course so that's why we
do what you do
it
i don't know i do it for the culture god
damn
so that's the big news of the day that
should have been story number one that
should have been story number one but
instead it's it's our lead story uh
that's really what's been going on with
us
amongst other things i'm trying to make
baby food big yikes oh my god i thought
you were gonna say i'm trying to make
babies i'm like you're kidding me
no i'm trying to make baby food now and
i'm struggling to get the right
consistency machinery
you know i i had an epic fail with the
baby brezza and no shade to baby brezza
because i love the bottle sterilizer but
their baby food maker is just a piece of
crap
yeah i'm not gonna lie uh you sent me
this gorgeous like gorgeous beyond and
getty type of photo of harry looking so
stunning um while eating dinner and he
had some [ __ ] on his plate it was
carrots that looked you know at 40
carrots so they give you that like wet
carrot thing with all your sandwiches
yeah continue continue to make fun of
the food that i
like made
from scratch know your scratch yeah yeah
make fun of that first
it's [ __ ] up for sure i just um i
could i just i know you're struggling
how about that
no but that that's what baby food looks
like girl
is this supposed to be like majorly
pureed yeah
i just looked a little chunky to me
that's it
you look a little chunky
oh i'm kidding my
i can say that because you're so [ __ ]
snatched these days i could vomit
chunksters
get her
i can only say that because you actually
are not and you're so smelt
i'm so jealous
wow
wow
wow wow
wow
and you know what you know who i don't
think would appreciate that comment
mama's mamas get her she came after my
homemade baby food okay you guys get her
yeah i came after your homemade baby
food you came after my soul
and if we weren't sisters [ __ ] i'd
climb through this [ __ ]
computer and strangle you okay oh my god
it's true and i'm only not upset because
i look stunning today you're stunning
every day these days and i'm just a
jealous wench what can i say okay that's
totally fine i am down officially 23
pounds
um and if you can acknowledge jealousy
like that's amazing that's what i said
like i could vomit i'm so jealous i'm so
proud of you you look insane and now you
can like now i can
make a joke you can make a joke yeah no
before you couldn't
too real
[Laughter]
too real
be real claude be unreal do you think
that you are going to like
get out of a phase of making your own
baby food and just buy it well that's
what everyone said like in the comments
on my instagram they were like you throw
it away and you go to the store and you
right there's apparently like a lot of
baby foods that have no additives i just
don't know how something can be on the
shelf and it's like actually just
carrots and nothing else like right
wouldn't it expire i definitely want to
give it a good try i'm definitely not
feeling disheartened enough yet and the
thing is like i i can't making baby food
can't be harder than nursing and pumping
24 7. a hundred percent so i am
committed for the time being but we
shall see i'll keep you guys posted i
got a different machine and i am sending
that baby so one back because it's
broken i feel like it's like one of
those classic things like baby number
one pureeing your own food baby number
two you can have crack yeah that's like
the oh crap that's like that commercial
first i think it's pampers not pampers
it's the other one like loves huggies
one of them and they're like
parents for baby number two because it's
like
yeah
they're less expensive i think and
they're just as good
right right like and it's literally just
like cotton yeah
yeah um
so you're making your own baby food um
any thoughts on cloth diapers
still
no
thoughts i follow actually i don't
follow it comes up all the time people
like talking about why i use cloth
diapers and the benefits and like i
totally get it for sure but like when
there's a duty in a diaper and you put
the diaper in the laundry
where does the duty go i think that
before you put it in the laundry like
you
white you get as much duty off as you
can you rinse it in the sink
and then it's just like stained speaking
of duty did you see kaylee and russell
dickerson's instagram stories yesterday
no
oh my god they posted the funniest thing
at first it was on their close friends
story and i was like oh my god this is
such good content but then they posted
on like public
so
their child like
they were like laying in bed the child
was supposed to be asleep and they like
look on their camera and kaylee turns to
russell and it's like i think our son is
like holding his duty
so they run in and literally he has judy
all over his but he pulled his duty out
of his diaper and like it was on his
hands his face his sheets
kaylee was being so funny about it i
could not stop laughing because it's
like one of those things that is so
insane like you just have to laugh that
is so crazy so funny i didn't know that
that was a possibility
and i didn't know i was on kaylee
dickerson's close friend story and now i
will be checking it routinely oh that's
exciting i'm gonna go watch that story
when we're done
apparently it's like a common issue not
common but it's not like uncommon it's
like a behavioral thing that a lot of
kids go through and it's like a really
um like difficult time for the parents
because i think it takes a couple weeks
for them too
what if you put him in a onesie how
could he get in there that's what people
had suggested but at certain at a
certain point like your child grows out
of a onesie like michaela doesn't really
wear a lot of onesies no she has proper
pajamas but it sounds like a onesie
would be a solve yes a onesie is um
people were suggesting on her instagram
a good solution great okay so mama's
we're solution-oriented mamas today if
your kids are picking judy out of their
own diapers no it's not an uncommon
issue you're not alone and there's a
onesie for that
great okay you learned something new
every day here yeah
um
so that's really all i have to say on i
just wanted to come on here and like
give my acceptance speech for 100k and
then be hilarious and deliver the past
five with my best gal pal oh love that
for us i just have one small update
because i was up so late finishing every
summer after
what did you think i know margot didn't
love it by the end i liked it so much
more than when i started because when
you start it's like okay so she's like
30 and like kind of sad and miserable
and then the flashbacks are to a 13 year
old getting her period i'm like what am
i doing reading this book by the end
she's like 30 and figuring her life out
and
she's eight the flashbacks she's 18 and
like making big life choices so i was
like okay great um and i really really
liked it by the end of it i'm still glad
that snitch didn't pick it for the
redheads because it just i don't need to
dissect it like yeah uh it's not that
deep it's not that deep at all but
i think when i got into bed last night i
was at like 60 and i just like couldn't
i needed to know what happened and what
the thing was and i think i was up to
like 11 30 reading which is why i'm so
[ __ ] tired okay so this is about to
be a spoiler alert for the books if you
haven't read it feel free to like press
forward 30 seconds um
what did you think of the final line of
the book
what was the final line that she was
proposing to him oh
oh i was like okay becca kufrin um i was
reading it i'm like this is the best
book i've ever read nothing can make
this book bad epilogue i'm like crying
i'm like this is amazing final line i'm
like i have to reread it i'm like
there's no way she's proposing to him
again
champion of women over here
we deserve to be proposed to in hetero
relationships agreed it didn't bother me
because i feel like
it didn't bother me because he had
proposed to her and she turned him down
and so i kind of feel like
the ball is in her court that's why good
point
that's why she was doing it because i
mean to propose to someone they turn you
down and even if things get better like
wouldn't you just like feel a little
weird about doing it again like it has
to be on her
to do it and then i'm sure he would
propose to her again but she needed to
to pick up the mantle okay i have to say
like that definitely i totally had
forgotten that he had asked her um and
i'm so glad we're talking about this
because that was like a piece of the
book i i couldn't make if he had never
proposed to her uh yeah no like that
would have been really weird okay you
know what oh my god i feel so much
better
um
my book update is a book i told you
about yesterday i finished and it was
[ __ ] amazing five stars there was a
twist that i
could not believe and i wasn't even
expecting a twist because the book was
really good like i didn't need a big
twist
what's the book
the secrets of us
it's free on prime 230 pages and it's
incredible i loved it i'm going to add
it to my goodreads right now so i don't
forget
it's like a
twisty thriller
twisty thriller okay is it spooky
no there was one scene that was spooky
and i was like home alone and i was
quaking but other than that it's totally
fine
okay
you should read a flicker in the dark
i know i get like really scared easily
by books like it's like for me when i
was younger and i used to watch like a
lot of law and order every now and then
an episode would like freak me out and i
like couldn't go to sleep um and
sometimes like i feel like that could
happen with me with books like scary
books
well the book like while you're reading
it you're very into it but there's
nothing in it that's like gonna keep you
scared i think yeah oh we also didn't
even talk about like together privately
or here on the podcast yet um that
people are loving our remote setup which
brings me so much joy like i got so much
positive feedback from our audio
listeners and our video yes listeners
yesterday because you know obviously i'm
change averse i was worried like the
show would never be the same
um
people were like i literally forgot
claudia wasn't in florida i listened as
a podcast the audio was premium i
couldn't even tell you guys were in
separate rooms and video everyone loved
even though
i thought i had like a a huge [ __ ] up
with my video i ended up getting a new
camera yesterday so today's will be even
better but everyone's like this is
amazing this is amazing and i just i
feel proud of us i feel proud of us too
and we still have like improvements to
come to make it you know as perfect as
it can be but i'm so glad that people
are liking it and that it is fire flames
because
we love doing the show and i really
wanted to be able to move and i'm glad
that i could yeah no i feel really i
feel really good and honestly this new
angle on you on youtube um it's just
more flattering for me um i don't feel
so exposed
visually so i'm at peace for sure yeah
no i like
i like the vibe and the feeling just
like it's very cozy in here i am wearing
my pajama pants still um because i
didn't know that you'd be able to see
them but just you guys they've had a
really long morning like
just it's fine leave it at that leave it
at that mama's
don't get her thank you mama's back down
mama's
white flag yeah no and my hair is like
so gross but i actually like can't wash
it because i don't have time to do it so
i just keep it gross that's fine yeah
slick the grosser the slicker however
huh that's what they do on tick tock
everyone's like literally putting
dirt in their hair to make it look good
oh is that what they're doing these days
on tick tock the dirtier the hair like
the clean girl aesthetic that everyone's
like obsessed with which is like really
dainty looking girls in like really
slick back buns and ponies they never
wash their hair and they douse it in
mousse to like make it really slick
interesting that's like the haley bieber
aesthetic right yes i've seen a bit of
that on reels
oh
wow it must be the then the clean girl
trend is officially over if it's on
rails no i don't know if i've seen it on
reels but i did hear about it somewhere
on instagram
yeah no it's it's not an aesthetic that
i can personally take on because i feel
like if you like if you guys don't know
like the clean girl aesthetic it's very
hilly bieber it's like natural makeup
it's like
like a little crop top with a jean and a
blazer and like a golden necklace and
just like skinny and
yeah
and i haven't seen the clean girl
aesthetic on a big face or like people
who actually need to wear makeup like
it's easy to be clean girl aesthetic
when you're 16 and you have like perfect
skin and perfect everything
um so it's just a trend i can't
particularly you know participate in
which is sad is there a tick tock
aesthetic that you do feel like is yours
coastal grandmother but you're not a
coastal grandmother today today you're
like 70s hippie grandma
well i came i've been up for 52 hours i
was up early this morning at a brand
event for captain crunch and it was on a
boat and it was like you know captain
crunch crunch berries very colorful so i
wanted to be on theme so this set i'm
wearing which is from zara it's like
colorful i thought it was giving crunch
berry
it is giving crunchberry yeah like and i
got complimented it on by the girlies
who work for captain crunch who are
obviously toasters
shout out to captain crunch maddie the
team toasters love it it's giving crunch
berry
it it's getting crunch berry are you
you're a crunchberry aesthetic
yes that's kind of like the era i'm
currently in i love that for you
thanks um so i feel like we've got a
great show for everyone today five
glorious stories big news with serena
williams yep we'll be talking about it
you guys know i don't know if i've
mentioned this here before but i have a
deep connection to serena williams i did
write my senior thesis in college on her
and i got the only a i've ever gotten in
my life i don't think i knew that
oh i feel like it's one of those dennis
funeral stories i say it all the time no
fresh story alert oh my god yeah so it
was the longest paper i ever had to
write it was about 20 pages and
i just like really
i don't know why i chose serena williams
but i learned so much about her and i
got an a like when i checked it was the
year i graduated so like i didn't really
care about my grades and i went to go
check my grades and there was like an a
on my final and i swear to god i thought
i thought i logged into someone else's
portal i was like this cannot be correct
so what were you saying about her
well it was really about like the media
representation of serena williams how
one how she's compared
like um verbally to men and one how
she's compared verbally to white players
and
the verbs that like the new york times
uses to
refer to serena williams are so [ __ ]
derogatory like beastly but maria
sharapova is like elegant you know no
um and then a lot about her hair like it
was really um
because the class was called race and
ethnicity and it was just about serena
williams as a tennis player but also as
a black woman and it was like i think it
was really good and so did my professor
i got an a that's amazing so i feel
deeply connected to serena williams for
that reason and we had the opportunity
to meet her like four years ago and she
was a doll and a half and she was
[ __ ] hilarious yeah no you i don't
think you've told that story before and
you know i remember so i feel like i'm
always telling that story and it's so
sad because when we met serena williams
we took a picture that um should be
illegal for how [ __ ] ugly it is and i
would love for this to be one of those
moments where like i posted on the toast
instagram and everyone like last i
literally will never in my life let that
photo see the light of day and i did i
did post it on my instagram story at the
time so [ __ ] face tuned like it was a
fun house mirror and it still was one of
the worst photos of me to ever grace the
internet i don't i remember meeting her
but i don't remember this photo it's the
three of us me you and serena
you need to send it to me i'll send it
to you yeah yeah because i don't
remember
it's horrifying it was your bob days and
it was my mole days so dark bob and mole
mole and bob
so we'll get into serena amongst other
things
in the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
fashion pass we know so many toasters
already love fashion pass it is truly
the stiniest clothing renting service
you get unlimited rentals for one flat
price their clothes are everything of
the sort they have so much
you save so much money because you're
not out buying clothes all the time and
they have the best brand so obviously
there are other rental services for
clothing but i think what really sets
fashion pass apart is like actually cute
stuff it's easy to rent ugly crap like
no one wants that fashion pass is like
really current things and brands that
are on revolve currently they have
amanda up richard up richard up
upperjard i can never remember
um for love and lemons free people show
me your moomoo like stuff you actually
want in your closet
um
and you're spending 200 on an outfit
that you're gonna wear on vacation take
a picture in and never wear again no
rent it
and the best part is that if you find
something you really really love um and
you want to keep it you get a huge
discount if you purchase it directly
from fashion past it can be anywhere
from 30 to 60 off it's just a better
option than constantly shopping it's
sustainable it's good for the
environment it's good for your
house not becoming cluttered you can
keep that kim k clean aesthetic and we
have a special discount code for the
toasters today if you go to
fashionpass.com use code toast at
checkout you'll get 40 off your first
month so you can try it for just 39
that's unlimited rentals for just 39
with code toast today's episode is also
brought to you by third love third loves
24 7 classic t-shirt bra delivers on
style and comfort and that's why it's
their number one bra millions of women
agree this bra makes their boobs happy
so third love is a company that is just
saving lives it's saving people's backs
their necks and just overall comfort i
think the beauty of third love is they
really actually are the only company
i've ever bought bras from that help you
find your size like what your actual
size is not like a fake size a real size
and their bras are so comfortable
they're seamless i have had so many
problems with bras with straps being too
tight cups being too small digging into
my back and it's just because i really
never knew my actual size and i think
the sizing system and the quiz that they
give you at third love are so genius
and their best-selling bra which is the
24 7 classic t-shirt bra it forms to
your body it makes your boobs look their
best the straps will not slip and
there's no pinching or digging they
invented half cups so you'll always get
the right fit that's the beauty of third
love they come in sizes a through h and
they also like i said have those
exclusive half cup sizes feeling is
believing so give your boobs the 24 7
comfort and support you deserve upgrade
your bra today and get 20 off your first
order at thirdlove.com toast so it's 20
off at thirdlove.com
toast you might have been wearing the
wrong size bra in just the wrong bra
your whole life and you don't know that
it's even an issue until you try a third
love god that's exactly what happened to
me
and until you have the right bra
then you're like
whole world oh then you're like oh this
is living
yeah
are you ready for our stories
yes
our first story is some sad news olivia
newton-john has died at the age of 73
after a 30-year battle with breast
cancer
olivia newton-john the grammy
award-winning singer and actress best
known for her role in greece died on
monday after battling breast cancer for
30 years she passed away peacefully at
her ranch in southern california this
morning surrounded by her family and
friends read a statement posted to her
facebook uh the statement said we ask
that everyone please respect the
family's privacy during this very
difficult time
olivia has been a symbol of triumphs and
hopes for over 30 years sharing her
journey with breast cancer her healing
inspiration and pioneering experience
with plant medicine continues with the
olivia newton-john foundation fund
dedicated to researching plant medicine
and cancer
they asked for donations to her fund in
lieu of flowers
this was so like unexpected and sad and
also just like so weird because
yesterday for the first time i think in
literally two years we were talking
about john travolta on the toast um and
then i saw john travolta's tribute and
it was like it actually brought tears to
my eyes he was like you're danny like it
was
it was so cute um
and this is so sad um i feel like she's
been really like open publicly over the
years about her
struggle with breast cancer and i think
she's kind of like a multi-generational
queen like obviously
millennials and older boomers everyone
knows her from greece but then she had
like an iconic role on glee um and she's
just her songs like even if you're not
familiar with olivia newton-john like
you of course know her iconic songs from
greece and she's just a cultural icon
and this is so sad this is so sad who is
she on glee
i think she was herself oh very cool
yeah they did i think like maybe a
grease episode i don't remember what it
was she did let's get physical
let's get physical
but that's not from greece
no that's one of her songs though
but you said you know
i i don't remember honestly oh okay yeah
no this is very very sad um i think
everybody is feeling the loss so many
celebrities have like penned tributes
that just so many celebrities have
posted videos of themselves singing
hopelessly devoted and i wanted to talk
about that
so really well i wanted to know if you
think that is an um like appropriate or
like
um
respectful way of honoring someone like
like kissing no not the day
that they pass away it's like here's me
writing
their song like
yeah it's a little strange and it also
depends on like the medium like did you
perform it at a you know a big thing and
you're posting that clip or you're just
like hopping on to show how you can yeah
and by the way i'm not calling anyone
out like i know everyone's gonna be like
remy posted and remy's video she looked
amazing but i saw literally 10 people do
and i was like this is this a trend and
then i saw it on like instagram and tick
tock and i was just like
i've never seen that before where like
somebody passes away like a musician and
then everyone starts posting videos of
themselves singing i'm and i'm not
calling anyone out i just want to talk
about like okay trend in general yeah no
it's
a little like hey look at me
right but like
i'm not really above asking you to grace
us with hopelessly devoted today and
like that would be weird yeah
yeah even though it's one of my favorite
songs to sing so without further a did
it do no i'm kidding um i already have a
tick tock up from like a couple years
ago if you want to go look um i just
thought that was interesting it is
interesting and if i didn't want you to
sing it so bad right now i would go
harder on the people who did that but
you know i think it's like i can't i
can't go hard on them because like i
could have been one of them you know i
just probably was busy yeah yeah exactly
i'm hopelessly devoted
to you
so i think in general it is like a nice
way of honoring her like it's an iconic
song of hers and like you know the more
you sing it every time you sing it like
her spirit lives on
i do think it's like a weird reflex to
be like let me sing
she passed but since we have been
talking about her for a while now like
i'm ready for it
for the song
for me
it's yeah
no i was going to say something but i
shouldn't but i'm up but now there's
nowhere to hide since you pushed my love
aside
i'm out of my head
hopelessly devoted
to you
[Music]
hopelessly devoted
to you
[Music]
by the way this is literally going to
get us copyrighted and our eligible
plaque removed it's fine it was less
than 10 seconds and that was beautiful
and even though yes in theory there is
something weird about making it about
you
i really enjoyed that tribute
yeah and i enjoyed like other people's
tribute like kelsey ballerini did one i
saw a bunch of people on tick tock who
like i don't know
um personally do it they sounded great
remy sounded amazing and i was just like
wanting to talk about and i really can't
stress enough like i'm not coming for
anyone like i love everyone who did it
i'm just genuinely like i thought it was
an interesting trend that people were
commentating on the trend yeah and i
have to say like
i don't know if i've ever spoken about
this but like there was a time in my
life like at a young age when i was like
coming to understand that i had like a
really beautiful singing voice um and
the song that i
came to that conclusion with was
hopelessly devoted i don't know if you
remember like i used to sing that song
on the car ride home from school like 45
times a day
no i i don't really remember that yeah
it was like a it was like a thing
oh it was a thing okay yeah it just
wasn't there yeah
well that was beautiful and
thank you for that you're welcome and uh
rest in peace olivia
newton-john also another thing i saw
like a trend like people um like on
social media being like r.i.p but they
did like capital r lowercase ip
and i just feel like i feel like that's
disrespectful like rip olivia you know
no i saw like a few people do it and
it's like just take that extra time to
do it all capital
yeah like if you can't even put like the
period in between
like but i don't even need the periods
like i just need all capitals it felt
really like disrespectful i'm being
serious it's just so [ __ ] lazy and
like if you don't even have the time to
put in capitals like we don't need your
rip no and like you obviously don't care
like you're doing this for content not
for like to honor someone who touched
you yeah i agree
rip olympia i think that's
really more disrespectful
like and it's like people just feel like
they need to post something so often and
it's like you really don't like if
if you can't take the time to to
actually say something or even to put
periods or uh capitalizations on rip
then we don't need to hear from you
right this is like a serious thing it's
not like a regular social media post or
a tweet like i it just i sort of like i
saw it once and i was like oh that's
weird and i said like two more times on
twitter and i was like
that's like rude yeah
yeah that is weird i i never thought of
it but you're right
yeah i don't know why i was like judging
the way everyone was grieving on social
media yesterday but that's what i was up
to
love that for you thanks
our next story other big news of the day
serena williams announces she will
retire from tennis after the 2022 u.s
open so serena williams is on the cover
of vogue and called serena's farewell
she says i'm terrible at goodbyes and
she penned
um an essay on why she's retiring from
tennis in 2022 and it is the september
issue right so it's like a really big
deal for her to be on the cover right
it is the september so i didn't even
realize that so it's like a huge deal
for vogue huge deal for serena i think
that's this is really like a beautiful
way to announce it because it's like a
huge milestone to be on vogue september
issue and then also like it's a career
milestone for her retiring from tennis
so i think whoever was in charge of like
the marketing genius yeah i forgot about
the fanfare about the september issue
and this hits all the marks
um i'm just like cursing myself for not
purchasing us open tickets prior
because now like the women's finals and
the women's semifinals tickets are going
to be so expensive and i really want to
go now
yeah you should go
i know
i should you know brian always gets like
free tickets because like you know the
the sponsors are always like airlines
credit cards banks yeah go with them
that's like if you know fashion pass for
the sponsor obviously i would get free
tickets for him it's american express
we're different like that it was captain
crunch right right so i um
i really
want to go now and i don't really didn't
really have interest and go to the us
open before that so hot
yeah no you should go it's it's a nice
experience and this is historic
yeah
she talks about like why she's now
retiring and ultimately comes down to
prioritizing like being a mom and family
and not being able to
do it all as they say she talks about
how if she were a man she wouldn't have
to make this choice of course her wife
would be home birthing babies
breastfeeding going through all of it
and it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's crazy i
was just reading uh maybe i knew this at
the time but it hits different now in
2017 at 35 she won the australian open
while eight weeks pregnant with her
daughter
and she came back playing through
postpartum depression and while
breastfeeding
and she's also been so vocal like such a
good advocate for mamas like talking
about working as a mom being getting
back in physic good physical shape as a
mom i watched her documentary she talked
about it a lot um
[Music]
the one the documentary about her
wedding but it was also like her trying
to get back in shape for the wedding and
for like a tennis upcoming tournament
she was like super vulnerable i stan
like so completely she's like probably
the greatest tennis player of all time
cross
cross-gender
like i would say she's
she's the best
player of all time right
it's hard to say cross gender because
it's so different i mean the sport is
different
for men and women like the amount of
games played and everything um yes
i feel like if she played novak djokovic
who for some reason i [ __ ] hate like
why
i don't know i just something about his
face it reminds me maybe of someone i
like went to middle school with who i
didn't like i am so triggered by him
like if someone's watching us open and
it's novak djokovic against literally
anyone i'm rooting for the other guy
um i'm looking at his face
he doesn't bother me whatever actually
like him no i'm a i'm sorry
i love when he picks his wedgies like
he's so cute
um but i agree with you that serena
williams is the greatest of all time i
don't know what happened what would
happen if she played novak djokovic i
think she would win dead ass
i would love to see that uh i think she
should do it before she goes out isn't
that the premise of that movie with
about billie jean king
you know i'm not a bjk
stan in the sense that i really don't
know a lot about billie jean me neither
except i do know that she's not my lover
she's just a girl who thinks that i am
the one
the kid is by the way
when you think of the kid is not my son
what do you think of that thing to
chiara in montana
i don't know where we were like someone
at camp used to think that was the words
do you want an apple in spanish and they
used to sing it and then they told us
that and i think we like
made fun of them relentlessly as we
should no it sounds exactly like chukere
yeah
that's also wet dream tomato yes yes wet
tomato concrete jungle wet tree tomato
there's nothing you can't do
um
i would love to see serena play novak
now i'm i'm hung up on that yeah but i
agree she is the goat
she's the goat she's an icon for women
for tennis players for athletes for
mothers for women who are actually
beautiful right
um percent for women who actually
possess the vernacular they believe they
possess yeah
um and the sp like i feel like
i've never been like obsessed with
tennis but whatever it's on especially
the us open like i always keep up and
she's just been like a pillar in the u.s
open like for my whole life so
i love her does that mean she's also
retiring from her doubles career with
venus
i think tennis is tennis yeah
this is so sad i mean obviously every
great athlete has to retire at some
point how old is she
great question i think she's in her 40s
that's so crazy
i just would like to confirm that yeah
but i don't know if i can do it in time
just google serena williams age oh
that's true
where were you going i was just
scrolling through the article i was
reading
oh but you're um she's 40. she's going
to be confirmed great
um so you know that's a respectable age
to retire i'm wishing her the best i
don't think this is the last we'll see
if her she's you know business woman
mogul she's always you know doing stuff
um but thank you serena for your
amazing career it's really been a joy
and a pleasure to watch it really has
been
looking forward to see what she does
next hope she gets everything she wants
me too and i hope she finds peace in her
retirement and can focus on family yeah
that's true
are you ready for our next story yeah
oh no
spoke too soon is it the next story that
happens to be brought to you by
pear eyewear yes
oh
what a little kawinki dink i love when
that happens you are a unique mash-up of
all of your favorite things and there's
a multitude of ways to express yourself
so celebrate all that you are and
explore who you can be with customized
prescription glasses from pear eyewear
don't let wearing glasses bring you down
like para eyewear is totally
customizable you should have a different
pair of eyewear for
every shirt in your closet like you're a
stylish gal going out on a date going to
work meeting friends like change it up
with pear eyewear they are fiercely
individual and they lead by example it's
a single company that is creating an
illusion of choice in the eyewear
industry and keeping their prices
artificially high pair eyewear has
forged their own way and designs all
their looks in-house so you get high
quality eyewear at a fraction of the
price a pair for a pair so that's also a
great part of a pair i wear for every
pair purchased pair will provide glasses
and vision care for children around the
world
get glasses as unique as you are one
pair infinite style starting at just
sixty dollars when you go to pear
eyewear.com toast that's 15 off your
first purchase when you go to
p-a-i-r-eyewear.com
toast is an affordable way to keep your
style changing match your glasses to
your blouse your glasses to your scarf
your glasses to your shoes anything
customizable stylish pair i wear dot com
slash toast
great thank you so much
an update from yesterday's story anne
hey she's in a coma and has not regained
consciousness since her l.a car crashed
as a rep anhesh's condition has not
improved in the days following her fiery
la car crash a rep for the emmy winner
said in a statement to people that she
is now in critical condition at the
hospital quote she has a significant
pulmonary injury requiring mechanical
ventilation and burns that require
surgical intervention she is in a coma
and has not regained consciousness since
shortly after the accident she was in a
blue mini cooper on friday that crashed
into a mar vista home rented by a woman
the residents caught fire resulting in
the emmy-winning actress suffering
bourbons from the incident she was then
intubated in the hospital
so i feel like when you get into a
really bad
like
fire burning incident don't they put you
in a medical induced coma because
the pain of your skin burning is so
painful that you might go into shock and
like potentially die
i i don't know
so i was just curious if she was in a
coma from that or from like head
injuries
sustained that's interesting the way
that they're phrasing it makes it seem
like it's not a medically induced coma
one because they're giving information
so what did they say a medically induced
coma and they and do do they take you if
it's a medically induced coma do they
take you out of it or you have to regain
consciousness on your own
i think they could take you out so
they're saying she has not regained
consciousness so
oh like as if she had a
choice right
got it
um also i just wanted to correct myself
apparently anna haiti i said yesterday
was never on celebrity apprentice so
perhaps i was thinking of someone else i
wonder who you were thinking of
i swear like i swear to god she was like
i'm telling you i don't care what google
says she was i mean we could look up who
was on that season season and maybe
there's someone else with like a pixie
cut
you were thinking
yeah but i'm telling you i i wouldn't
know who anne haight is
anyway
so like if if i didn't know her from
that
where did i know her yeah
okay here's who was on season eight
ready
are you ready
joan rivers annie duke oh my god jesse
james not decker sandra bullock's
excellency he went really far he did
really good
yeah and actually obviously like what we
know about him
is not
you know indicative of this but on the
show he was p john and he was still
married to sandra at the time and it was
crazy how he wouldn't work his like
connections
to raise money through like her and her
fancy friends
brandi roderick who's a playboy playmate
and actually she went really far too
um melissa rivers
uh herschel
walker oh sorry clint bucky i skipped
right by him country star
are you ready for our next oh so that's
the update on anne hey she'll keep you
posted the story just gets crazier and
crazier and
um
i just you know hope she pulls through
are you ready for our next story camila
cabello has confirmed her relationship
with lox club ceo austin kevich
camilla cabello confirmed she's dating
uh dating austin kevich by showing
plenty of pda with the locks club
founder less than a year after her
breakup from shawn mendes the two
stepped out for a public walk in l.a on
sunday according to photos obtained by
the daily mail they were spotted on a
stroll while holding hands as they
playfully chatted with each other
at another point the duo enjoyed some
breakfast while relaxing at a picnic
table she was seen planting a big smooch
on his cheek and another sweet woman she
caressed his fudge
so yeah every time i hear about these
two and i think i said this maybe the
last time we spoke about it on the show
but i always feel like um
the way that it's reported like his name
is always the locks club ceo like it
feels sponsored like that would be like
if every time i'm spotted out which is
never it's the morning toast co-host
like it's so um
it's in the headline
that's true
tech founder
tech ceo
yeah businessman i don't know if it's
sponsored i mean i am glad for the
context and if it was just tech ceo i it
feels different than like locks club
founder you know tech ceo is like
evan spiegel
um but that is a very interesting point
you know what it reminds me of it's like
you know sophia richie's fiance yeah uh
cha-cha matcha i think
just businessman i think like i think
he's like does a lot of things i think
he started chachamacha
i don't think so
google
yeah i think he does like a million
things maybe he's like an investor in
cha cha matcha i just like saying cha
cha matcha me too even though like you
couldn't pay me to drink matcha cha-cha
okay sophia richie chacha matcha
she's probably been there before
yeah oh yeah that too no but he is the
founder
oh okay oh no no that was the other guy
she was
dating not her fiance no right not her
fiance her fiance's like a executive
okay okay so confusing i'm so confused
so many business men so many businessmen
it's hard to keep them apart but i do
appreciate when they let us know
especially when it's like a b2c business
that we would know about not the private
equity investor i don't think i would
know his
dealings but when it's like locks club
i'm like oh okay cool
yeah
no and like i i appreciate the reference
but i always just like my eyebrows perk
up a little bit like it's planted by
someone who has a large majority stake
in the lox club i just obviously have to
wonder if they met on locks club was
camila cabello on locks club and if she
wasn't a jewish man and this is actually
like bad advertising for the platform
because it's like the ceo didn't even
find his lady love on locks club that's
actually a really good point i'm glad
you pointed that out because i doubt
that they did the box club is a dating
app obviously um like for everyone but
it's mostly targeted towards the jewish
community that's why it's called the
locks club yeah
but you don't have to be jewish to join
or if you're looking for a jewish
partner you can join but it's mostly
centered
around like being culturally jewish i
choose to believe that camila cabello
was on the locks club
yeah i would love that i would love that
too but it does make me and i can't
believe i'm saying this i miss her and
sean
i like don't
they were i'm sorry i don't know why i
said that like i wasn't sure i don't
they were so cute and they were so happy
they were but there was also elements of
weirdness there like a lot of their you
know stage paparazzi pictures
um did you i don't know if you watched
his netflix documentary but we were like
we get it you like camilla cabello like
it was a little like
a lot
a little a lot yeah yeah also sean's
like not doing well
yeah so he's actually in hot water right
now because he um canceled a show i
don't know if he cancelled his whole
tour i think i maybe read that somewhere
because he was wanting to focus on his
mental health and he was posting on
social media that he was at the beach
with friends putting on sunblock and
stuff and you know a lot of people were
commenting like you're literally
supposed to be doing a show in boston
tonight i'm at the hotel that i was
supposed to be at because i couldn't get
my money back and you're at the beach in
florida
um so it was giving
anger
and i feel like for sean mendes fans to
like turn on him which
like he could fart in a bowl and they
would think it was literal
salad
um
for them to turn on him like they must
be really mad yeah but like
canceling your shows citing mental
health concerns but then being on the
beach with friends does jive you know
you you should be able to
right right it's not a contradiction
it's not like you're
doing things that are bad for mental
health the beach is extremely peaceful
yeah and good for your mental health and
being with your friends that is tough
for people who bought tickets and
aren't getting what they paid for and
are kind of stuck
of course like that's uh
but see i need to know more details on
when the show was supposed to be and
when he decided to cancel it like is it
giving adele people on the plane yeah
what do you think is a like the minimum
amount of time someone can cancel a show
that's acceptable like
a week a week i was gonna say
yeah me too
yeah
i mean i'm sure he thought about all
those things when he made the decision
to cancel and still canceling outweight
actually going and doing it
yeah yeah yeah i hope he's doing well
honestly i truly wish him the best i
hope he finds love
do you know like how everyone says it's
giving share
no
and like this whole it's giving thing i
mean i know it's giving it's everyone's
favorite term
it really blew up on tick tock because
shawn mendes said it's giving share like
when describing something oh and he kind
of coined the term it's giving
he didn't coin it but people started
using it a lot more because then they
were like it's giving share and then
they were just like it's giving
got it
okay i like the phrase because it's very
i know exactly what we're trying to say
like it connotes this it connotes yeah
um but it's overused and it's going to
be ruined in a few days
yeah and it's giving over usage it's
giving over usage yeah
[Laughter]
okay are you ready for a fifth and final
story
i really am it's just a little random
news about everyone's favorite guy ned
stark
the game of thrones alum his real name
is sean bean thinks that intimacy
coordinators spoil the spontaneity of
sex scenes
wait
hold on i forgot that i have something
to do before the fifth and final and
you've got to repeat that because i have
no [ __ ] idea what you just said
this very confusing fifth and final
story is brought to you by all birds
summer is here and that means hotter
temperatures and longer days but it also
means more opportunities to get outside
and make the most after work happy hours
and impromptu picnics and you know what
else summer needs a shoe that's up for
anything introducing the tree breezer
flat from all birds breathable super
supportive and can keep you comfortable
from morning to night so the tree
breezer is a ready for anything flat
that's made from breathable tree
material the eucalyptus fiber is
moisture wicking and odor reducing it is
perfect for hot summer days and it
couldn't be easier to clean toss it in
the washing machine air dry for the
perfect refresh a wide range of colors
for every occasion mood and season and
there is something so deeply special
about special about shoes that can go in
the washing machine like thank you for
your service why can't all shoes do that
all birds are super comfortable whether
you're getting really active or you just
have a busy travel day ahead of you or
you just want comfy shoes that are also
really cute check out all birds and the
tree breezer snapshot are really cute
they're lightweight breathable and cushy
all day the tree breezer is your secret
to a comfy summer find your perfect pair
at allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com
okay i'm gonna take this from the top so
sean bean the actor is talking about
intimacy coordinators so intimacy
coordinators are becoming the industry
standard on film and tv sets but some
actors still resist their input
including sean bean who believes they
can be an impediment to actors the pr
and sean bean played ned stark yes but
he also has who the [ __ ] was ned stark
[ __ ] on game of thrones not on game
of thrones but on he's had a lot of
other roles
including [ __ ] the movie uh lady
chatterley's lover which is a big movie
he had a big sex scene in that so he's
[ __ ] what
he's [ __ ] he was [ __ ] back in 1993.
oh anyway so
so you could say his um
experience is a little outdated perhaps
yes but these days they're bringing
intimacy coordinators onto set to
make it look better to stage the sex
scenes more and he says he thinks it
would inhibit me more because it's
drawing attention to things somebody
saying do this put your hands there
while you touch this thing he said i
think the natural way lovers behave
would be ruined by someone bringing it
right down to a technical exercise he
said on lady chatterley's lover it was
spontaneous it was a joy we had a good
chemistry between us and we knew what we
were doing was unusual because she was
married i was married but we were
following the story we were trying to
portray the truth of what d h lawrence
wrote he also spoke about television
companies are
advertising advertisers censoring his
work but anyways i want to talk about
what you think about sex scenes
well i just want to say like ned stark
um i like actually disagree with him and
he sounds like a [ __ ] creep honestly
like i want to be natural like you're
acting first of all so like what you're
not upset that like you get directed in
other scenes but you're upset when you
get directed in the sex scenes like
i don't agree with him at all and i
think that like those intimacy
consultants or whatever i think a huge
part of their job is making sure like
both people feel comfortable and safe
which is huge because i think a really
big problem and i think they talked
about this on the affair
which which was a show with a lot of
nudity like a lot of the actors like
talked about the environment just
feeling really unsafe and awkward and
not comfortable um
so i don't agree with this at all and
like sorry you can't be naturally
[ __ ] someone when you're acting [ __ ]
like i don't agree at all
oh that's so funny my take was kind of
different but i do agree with you
ultimately like yeah like that's a
little weird
i can't even imagine how weird it would
be to one have to film a sex scene and
then have someone there like telling you
you're like doing it wrong and like
you're just trying to
do your thing i also just saw um like a
related article about chris pratt and
jennifer lawrence when they had to film
their sex scene for passenger they
shared a bottle of wine before and then
got to doing their thing and like i
imagine it is really awkward and i think
see i actually totally disagree i think
being natural and having wine together
before and like then maybe being like
kind of like weirdly intimate in front
of people
where you're supposed to be acting is
weird i think if someone's there
pointing out being very technical it
makes it way less weird because it's so
like obvious and prevalent that this is
staged like it's acting but if you're
going to pretend to be natural and whine
and dine someone and then have a bunch
of people watch you pretend to [ __ ] her
i think that's actually weird and then
keep in mind if you if you're married or
you have a partner and it's like you're
trying to get into this and be natural
and be natural that's cheating
i think it's weird and then of course it
always brings me back do you know what
i'm about to say
no
to the guy from desperate housewives
that actor with platinum white hair i
forget his name in real life who refuses
to um kiss or be intimate um with
respect to his wife um so he won't
accept roles where he has to kiss and
like he was married and dating and
desperate housewives and he like
literally never kissed anyone because he
loves his wife too much which is like
really sweet but really [ __ ] weird
honestly and he should get a different
job like i don't think you have to kiss
anyone if you're an accountant no but
he's doing pretty good for himself
considering he has that boundary and i
think is he yeah he gets plenty of roles
he's always the creepy guy in the
background i've never seen him after
desperate housewives oh no he's on other
stuff hold on what was his name on
desperate housewives
dave desperate
housewives
i feel like once a year we have this
conversation and we like go to his imdb
i swear to god okay his
his um
[ __ ] neil mcdonough
is his son
and he is also in he was in yellowstone
oh wow he was one of those brothers if
everyone remembers
good for him yeah i love him as an actor
i like him too i just think it's like a
weird flex it is but like if ben were an
actor
would you allow i'm not put the thing is
ben's not an actor so i'm not doing that
but
okay i think it's both really weird like
i think like to be
to not want to do it and like refuse is
kind of weird but i also think like the
way in which
trained actors like are so flippant and
like
carefree about it like not even
acknowledging at all even the slightest
bit that it's weird yeah like they're
like no they're like it's not weird but
like it is and you can acknowledge it
and still do it for a living but like
why are you lying to me yeah
they're like no it's literally just like
sitting down and doing a scene except
you're kissing someone like
the ignorance and like the refusing to
admit like the smallest bit of
awkwardness like that i think is just as
weird as refusing to do it all together
yeah and i think there's a difference
between like the kissing scenes
and
sex scenes
yeah of course of course and some of
these sex scenes are out of control like
i think back to like how joan rivers
always used to say she couldn't say gay
on
television on cable so she
used to say dancer when she meant to be
speaking of get like gay men um and how
we went from that to like literally i
just watched them the other day i saw
butthole like it's crazy yeah it is
crazy and also um these comments are
coming at the same time as the house of
the dragon
prequel game of thrones prequels coming
out and apparently like it is so
sex scene like more than ever
yeah
well game of thrones was so sexy and
then like then there was no sex yeah
well then the plot had to carry on and
there was like no time for all this
gratuitous sex but apparently the new
show is sex up the wazoo
wow i mean i'll never forget having to
watch brother and sister you know
do a doggy style in that tower at
uh white was a place called
in the north where the snows where the
snows lived why can't winterfell
that was really one of the most shocking
things i've ever seen in my life
[Laughter]
um
i'm really excited for the show though
it premiere me too and i'm excited to
recap it because those were the good old
days when we recapped game of thrones oh
some of the best times of my life says
some of the best times it premieres
august 21st on atrial max house of the
dragon
speaking of hbo max you know we spoke a
little while ago about how elvis was
going to be put on hbo max you know
they've decided not to put it on hbo max
unlike warner brothers has this
partnership with hbo max 45 days in the
theater everything goes on hbo max i
guess it's doing so well in theaters i
don't know for a fact that this is the
reason but what i presumed is that it's
doing so well in theaters they're not
going to pull it and put it on hbo max
i'm happy for them but i'm sad for us
but i'm glad it's successful
dev is devastated beyond belief i have
one thing to say
dog play i
get it frog
i get it
you understand you want a man who want a
man
do you want a man i want a man
hound dog
hound
oh you know the woman who sings
um the hound dog part in that dojo cat
song who i believe is also in the film
up and plays big mama thornton i'm not
100 sure because i haven't seen it but i
think that might be what it is she
passed away like a week ago maybe two
weeks ago
so sad she was in her 40s
terrible terrible
oh
crazy ugh well
those were the fastballs those were the
past five i guess i'll have to wait a
little longer to see longer longer to
see elvis
uh which is fine because i haven't seen
top gun haven't seen summer i turn
pretty haven't seen literally anything
in 12 years so fine
same
and those were the stories you needed to
know them i feel good about letting you
guys go into the world with the rest of
your day like being educated and knowing
these stories
yeah and i've loved hanging out with you
jax i've loved hanging out with my
hundred thousand subscribers and my
millions of fans worldwide hour millions
of fans sorry i'm right i always forget
you're here
and
that's our show right anything else
no i think that's all she wrote pencils
down
pencils down blue books shut
oof blue books that just brought me back
to like a really really bad time in my
life yeah
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast food
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcasting where podcasts can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i heart rate of catch box
all the places where you listen to the
podcast fine that's morning shall sleep
five about a beautiful stunning and
smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing amazing day today we'll see you
tomorrow
for hump day you know what you love it
it's hump day we'll see you then goodbye
goodbye
you